I've told you guys before that Jared Kushner,
Donald Trump's son in law, is truly a sinister
force in American politics and in the world.
And Jared's back, you know, after he did that one
Corona virus press briefing where he said things
like, you know, the stockpile is our stockpile.
It's not a stockpile for the states. They
pulled him out of public view because
he's been a disaster. Now he's back. Jared
Kushner reappearing on Fox News yesterday.
He was asked about the black American
community and he brought us a beautiful
message of hope and unity, which was, hey, listen.
Trump's policies have been the right policies, but
we can't make black people more success
sic successful than they want to be. We
can only help them so much. We can't make them
want to be successful if they don't want to
be successful. I guess that this is how Jared
Kushner thought he was defending Trump's policy
towards black Americans and other
minority groups. I don't know.
But take a look at this embarrassing fiasco
thing we've seen in a lot of the black community,
which is mostly Democrats, that President
Trump's policies are the policies that can
help people break out of the problems that they're
complaining about. But he can't want them to be
successful more than they want to be successful.
And what you're seeing throughout the country now
is a groundswell of support in the black
community because they're realizing that
all the different bad things that the media and
the Democrats have said about President Trump
are not true. And so they're seeing that he's
actually delivered his results in. A lot of people
want to get on board, start working with President
Trump because they know that, you know, unlike
most politicians who have been in Washington for
decades who talk and say all the right things.
President Trump may not always say the
right things, but he does the right things.
Is this the right message? Days before the
election, like maybe the calculation is
by saying this eight days before
an election, as he did yesterday,
he'll bring in more of the racist vote than the
number of other folks that will leave because of
the message. I don't know. And of course, Jared
Kushner's personal lack of self-awareness about
wanting to be successful, being what matters.
He was born with a silver spoon in his mouth.
Had businesses handed to him by his dad. His dad
essentially paid his way into Harvard. It is,
you know, the height of lack of self-awareness
and hypocrisy. It's just another instance, really,
of the same projection we've been seeing for
years with this family, major transition into the
second term. It's not our fault. They're just not
working hard enough. We can only help them succeed
so much. The guy was born on third base and he's
telling actual batters how to hit a triple. That's
the best analogy I can think of for this. And
honestly, when people say this stuff out loud,
how does he walk around without getting punched
in the face? Is it just 24/7 security that keeps
the guy from getting slapped? And by the way, this
idea of a groundswell of support for Donald Trump
from the black community, it's also a farce. The
latest IBD poll has Trump polling eight percent
with black voters. Another poll has Trump polling
seven percent with black voters. There is no
groundswell of black support for Donald Trump.
Now, many Republicans will say, oh, David,
the reason black voters aren't supporting Trump
is they've been tricked by the Democratic Party
into essentially signing a blank check for
them and voting for Democrats no matter what.
Which is really a way of saying black people
aren't actually evaluating candidates. They've
been tricked, which I guess means they're
not that smart. They've been tricked
into voting for the Democratic Party. Now,
the truth is black folks and Hispanic folks
and women and the college educated and on and on
all these groups that are supporting Joe Biden,
they're doing it because they know what Trump
offers and they don't want it. That's really the
reason black voters and others aren't supporting
Trump. But back to Jared Kushner and the idea
that Trump can only help black people so much
they have to help themselves. Is this just a
play for the racist vote? Have they calculated?
Let's bring in more racist whites will lose some
black voters if Jared says this, but we'll bring
in more racist whites who are overwhelmingly there
is more racist whites than black people. Watching
Fox News in the morning. Let's put let's let's
be let's be clear. Is it a calculation or am I
reading too much into it? There's no calculation.
It's just Jared being Jared and that's it. As
if you needed another reason to remove Trump,
we might be only a week out from never
having to hear from Jared Kushner again,
which for me is a really great incentive to vote
to remove Donald Trump, which I've already done.
This really is a reminder that the right has no
policy on broad based economic stimulus for the
lower and middle class, regardless of race. We.
In, say, the left's policy isn't good enough.
We can say the Democratic Party isn't left
enough on economic policy. But at least
the left thinks you need policy. Jared and
Republicans have this idea. You can't help
people if they won't help themselves, if they
won't pull themselves up by their own bootstraps
to revitalize a completely ridiculous idea. Why
can't poor people just decide to stop being poor?
Jared Kushner is frustrated that
poor people keep deciding to be
poor. That's what this comes down to. It's
a malignancy and we've got to remove it.